[Music]
hey everybody
welcome to project brussels this is
going to be a three-part video series in
which i recreate brussels the capital of
belgium and de facto capital of the
european union
in a full scale recreation albeit with a
not very high level of details you might
be able to tell
in city skylines and in addition to that
i should
add it's also going to be a bit of a
vehicle for me to talk about
my thoughts on city skylines as a game
its relation to the fields of urban
planning and urban studies
and also my personal experiences living
and studying in brussels these past few
years
and doing lots of things that are
related to serious gaming
now this might all sound a little bit
vague so let's get into it and i'll
explain more along the way
so first off i get comments all the time
about when i am going to play city
skylines again
and it's always felt a bit strange to me
because these past
years i've never really stopped playing
city skylines
i just stopped making videos of it ever
since 2017 or so
um but i've been sort of active in the
game
at least i participated in the global
build-off in 2018
and i attended pdxcon last year
i say last year but it was really 2019 i
just want to forget 2020 existed
where i met up with lots of other
players and asset creators and
people from paradox as well um i just
never really made content that i figured
would be worth it for my youtube channel
and brussels here is an example of that
to be completely honest i have had this
time lapse file on my hard drive for
almost a year i just never thought it
would be worth a video
and i don't know i'm just very hard on
myself sometimes when it comes to
putting out
um content and this recreation of
process is a lot lower
in detail than my usual builds
and definitely the usual city skylines
builds and even in the past year i think
the game has come so much
has come so far and so many new things
have come out that have completely
changed things that this is almost
completely outdated which is
part of the reason i've still felt
really hesitant to upload this
um but i think it's still worth talking
about and
i think it's a good backdrop for things
that i've wanted to discuss
on my youtube channel for so long i just
never really
found a good angle to discuss them with
and at this point i'm just thinking
you know what i'm just gonna have to
throw it into my usual time lapses and
just
rant about it and see where it goes from
there and
also i'm very curious how you guys
responses will be honestly because
that's
for me at least the main reason why i'm
publishing this video is to talk about
topics that have been on my mind
all this time um and then i would love
some more feedback on
because uh to give a bit more of an
actual reason why i'm making brussels
specifically and why i've been hiding
this from my youtube channel for a while
the past two years i was studying in
brussels specifically i was doing a
master's in urban studies
from the free university of brussels
which was really cool
a great experience and a great learning
experience as well
it's a it's a two-year program that's
quite broad and interdisciplinary so
it's a bit hard to define
and the courses go anywhere from urban
geography
and urban social studies to
things like urban planning and urban
design and mobility planning
so very hard to pin down but students
can
choose their own track to some extent in
terms of what they do with the program
and it's really interesting because it
brings people together from many
different corners
of academic discipline so personally i
was coming from a more sociology
background
but with an interest in cities and
architecture and the like
but many people also studying there were
architects or
coming from other kinds of urbanist
fields or
maybe even engineers there weren't any
specific engineers i think within
my class but we definitely shared
classes with them
so really interesting and really cool
experience in that sense especially when
you get into group projects but
i'm drifting way off topic how i
eventually ended up with city skylines
was one year into the program
when we had to start preparing our
master's thesis
at the time i was writing my master's
thesis
about the dutch housing policy
which if you live in the netherlands and
you actually landed a house in the
netherlands
congratulations the housing shortage is
huge over here
and it's a huge issue that's kind of
dear to my heart
so i wanted to write my master's thesis
about that and kind of halfway through
the process i realized that it was
something that i found very interesting
and important
but it was something where i also felt
like a fish out of the water and it was
just to
complex to tackle on my thesis
so i switched to something that's been
on the back of my mind for
a few years and i never really dared to
tackle
out of a sense that it's a very novel
topic and there isn't that much academic
literature on it
which is serious gaming and specifically
the use of city skylines in public
participation projects now public
participation
is kind of a broad term uh but it refers
generally to the process where citizens
of whichever city that may be
have some kind of say in the
developments or
the governing or policies in their city
and
usually this applies to when new
projects are developed or
certain changes are made to a
neighborhood and
the goal is to get the input from
citizens try to give them some power
uh try to strengthen the processes of
democracy
and give them some say in their in their
local neighborhood or
city whatever is happening and i'm
saying this very ambiguously because
it's quite a broad term and it can
reform
it can refer to many things but in the
context of city skylines
there is quite a bit of academic
literature
more than i expected honestly about the
potential of city simulation games in
public participation
and for many years simcity
has been the main game that academics
have targeted in this and there are many
interesting cases of simcity being used
in actual urban planning
not so much in the design phases but
definitely
in the participation of the public and i
think
given the fact that city skylines is a
game which goes much further than any of
the sim cities have ever gone
into realistically recreating city
layouts and giving
players the ability to customize the
game
create mods and import 3d models
there's the potential for many of the
same things that made these simcity
public participation processes
interesting while going
much further than them so that's why i
was really interested in
city skylines in that regard and it was
really cool to see that there's actually
a lot of academic literature on this
topic and there are actually some case
studies as well
there are a few cases mostly in
scandinavian countries
where either municipalities have come
forward
and tried to use city skylines in some
way or
in the case of norway even the prime
minister has played it on national tv
and it's been part of a political cycle
not to mention i've been part of one
such case study myself
in oslo.crp or as the making of it was
called on my channel project oslo
where students of the norwegian
university of life sciences could
showcase some of their disciplines
in city skylines on a real life map of
oslo
so altogether here i was as a student of
urban studies
really wanting to write my thesis about
this extremely niche and
nerdy topic of city skylines that for a
while
i was just really afraid of some sort of
academic stigma
against you know writing your thesis
about some stupid cultural topic
like your favorite cartoon or whatever
that stuff
tends to happen a lot but eventually i
figured you know i just
have to do this because if anybody is
going to write about this topic
um it's probably going to be me and i
think
in earnest it deserves a lot of
attention because city skylines is
quite special as a game anyway i could
also kill two birds with one stone
um maybe even three birds you could say
for one
i could add this to my thesis and it's
not going to be the crux in in any sense
it's just kind of a way to showcase the
game
and make it a lot more relevant and
interesting for the case of brussels
but also i was an intern at the time at
brussels major events which is the
city's free
event organization they organize markets
and
other stuff that happens in the city and
i was there specifically to build to to
help make a proposal for a cultural
space in the city about games
eventually i can already spoil it didn't
go through and
city hall didn't approve of the plans in
the end
but it was a really interesting project
to be a part of and i figured
this thing in city skylines could
probably be part of it
and of course the third stone is just
that i could
do my internship and get university
credits
while just playing a video game that i
already like playing anyway so
you know it would be a win anyway for me
[Music]
so that's very briefly the story of how
i ended up studying city skylines in
public participation
and why i am making brussels in the
first place
so now i want to say a little bit more
about my methods
in city skylines and how i'm approaching
this
um honestly this city is not going to be
very detailed
and that was just one of the core
reasons why i hesitated to put this on
youtube it's just
not that great of a build if you compare
it to other
game creations because some of the most
amazing and detailed builds are made in
city skylines and especially since the
game has come out
i think you've seen a gradual shift from
large-scale urban planning by some of
the main
modding youtubers and players i would
say to
highly detailed specific you know even
focusing on
certain junctions or procedural
objecting your own buildings and stuff
like this
so it's kind of shifted in a different
direction and this felt like it wouldn't
really fit into that
but anyway you know this is a good
vehicle to talk about some of these
topics that i find interesting
also another thing that i should mention
is that this recreation of brussels
is never going to be finished i might as
well say it up front here i know i
have a tendency to not be able to finish
many of the things that i start
but this one i know by now is not going
to be finished because it's just
impossible to do it in the game one of
the things that i set out to do
with this build is to try and more
specifically
showcase the technical limitations of
the game um
because there are just certain
limitations that you'll never be able to
get over in this game like the maximum
node counts
maximum network count there's a maximum
amount of
basically everything in this game and
some of the rules you can break
some of the rules you can bend it's a
bit like the matrix
but nobody's neo and nobody can
completely destroy the thing
so there's a the biggest problem that i
started running into uh very soon is the
fact that
there are not nearly enough node uh
network nodes
and um segments to be able to
build every road in brussels so i could
never build something
quite to the scale of the entire city
and always have to cut out some of these
suburbs and the outer areas
of the region uh my computer was also a
little bit of a technical limitation
because my pc is not that good
which on the one hand is good because it
means that i can make models that
showcase what a
decently average computer could actually
play and not what a super gaming rig
could do
um but it also means that i'm pretty
limited in what i can do myself
and then there's just the fact that i
wanted to just keep this
very minimal the idea was to create a
very very general recreation of brussels
without
a specific detail and then when you
wanted to have detail on a specific area
you could always go back to that area
change some of the streets add detailing
make the buildings more specific you can
actually go down
and actually plop up or ricoh some of
the buildings that you want to
but for this general recreation i wanted
to keep it simple
that's not to say i didn't have any
methodology i
did of course use an overlay as you can
see which i
made from open street maps i also
imported a very
basic road layout from the
importer although i didn't want to
import too many roads because it just
creates too many network segments and
too many nodes
which of course is problematic with the
maximum somewhere around
33 000 and then
also i didn't really know how to exactly
zone things because i was going to work
with zoning instead of ricoh so the
basic format that i'm following is
in interesting areas on google maps uh
become commercial districts
and the rest of residential districts
become residential
and then for industry and offices i'm
making exceptions per
building block and zoning those
according to
whatever the real life designation is
there
so that's the basics of how i come to
build this model
and now i just had to apply it to a city
of
almost 2 million people
now you'll have noticed that i cut this
video into different chapters
partly i'm doing that so i'm not
speaking the whole time and there's
actually
a little bit of quiet in there as well
not just my long
stream of consciousness but also
hopefully
that can make it a bit more clear what
i'm working on and what topics i'm
talking about at the same time because
this is quite a long video where i'm
doing
a lot of work that's all very similar
and basically looks the same the whole
time because
unlike most city skylines videos of
myself but
probably also of other people where
usually you're just working on one
neighborhood or block of buildings at a
time
i'm going to be laying down the entire
road layout of brussels almost
the entire road layout of brussels in
just this video
and each chapter is also actually a
separate recording
on a separate day as with these videos
i'm trying to squish the work of many
months
of work actually into some very compact
small videos
so i hope it makes sense it's a bit of
an experiment for me but
it also helps me be a little bit more
clear in what we're talking about
and keep a decent set of topics
throughout these videos
i want to file back actually a little
bit and go back to some of the earlier
chapters
the first chapter i guess uh was really
about the the city center
the second one about the zoning of the
city center and actually putting the
buildings in place
so here you could see where i am very
quickly
trying to get lots of buildings into the
map without having to plop a ball rico
everything
the third chapter was me working on
sanjil which
is a certain neighborhood to the south
of the city center which is really one
of the main
gentrifying areas in the city right now
and i guess a pretty
hip and happening place to be and right
here i'm working on excel and
which is a set of some of the richer
municipalities
and definitely some of the more quaint
and chic neighborhoods
in the city that are nonetheless still
pretty close
to the city center although then again
even
within these neighborhoods there's a lot
of distinguishable subcultures
and neighborhoods
[Music]
now what i just said is probably a good
segue to move into the topic
of what brussels is like as a city
because it's very complicated
and interesting technically brussels
isn't a city but a region
within belgium and belgium itself is
is a mess there are many youtube videos
you can watch about this
uh it has a very complicated
organizational structure
um there are seven different governments
within the country based on
different regions and languages but
something to
at least remember in this case is there
are three regions in belgium you have
the north which is flanders you have the
south which is oolonia
generally in flanders they speak dutch
or flemish
which is a dialect of dutch as exactly
the distinction between which there's a
lot of arguments about as well which i'm
not going to be delving into in this
video
and in the south in wolonia they speak
french and between that
sort of in the south of flanders but
very close to bologna as well
is brussels which is its own region
where people speak both dutch and french
and
supposedly the city is bilingual but in
reality
most of the people speak french and
while they do understand basic dutch
at least much more than the average
people in malunia
french has sort of become the lingua
franca of the city over the years
so there's that interesting
organizational structure of the whole
country and within this region
of brussels there is also a city of
brussels but this is really only the
city center
and some areas around that and then most
of the city
is actually made up of different
municipalities
which is not too unique many cities in
the world used to be made up of
different municipalities
it's just that most cities in the in the
world have also
started to conglomerate those
municipalities and become one
uh major municipality instead and that's
never happened in brussels
for a variety of reasons one thing that
i've heard a lot
is the fact that every municipality will
have its own mayor
that's a representative of that
municipality to the greater regional
council so
people often feel like their mayor is
the representation of their neighborhood
and you don't get swallowed by the huge
metropolis
and it's two million roundabout
inhabitants
um so that's an interesting dynamic i
guess
and there are lots of arguments to be
made either for
actually conglomerating all of these
municipalities and making one brussels
city
or leaving it the way it is honestly i'm
not even sure at this point which would
be better
but the result is that you do have very
distinguishable neighborhoods
so right here i'm working on eterbic and
autohim
which are also some of the richer suburb
municipalities
and it's the region where my university
is located it's this thing right here
this old uh military field actually
which is why it has that shape
on the left um and let's go into
some other stuff that i think is worth
talking about
[Music]
something which you may have noticed if
you've been paying very close attention
to the overlay that i'm working on which
by the way i know is not the greatest
overlay i ended up going for this
open street map screenshots because it
was the only thing that fit
perfectly to the geographical
representation of what i used to
import the roads and the terrain but
it's not looking so as well and
there will definitely be better overlays
in the future as i am saying this
i am aware of much better ways to do
this stuff but at the time
this was the best i could come up with
but yeah if you've been paying attention
to the overlay
you might have noticed that actually the
there are
words in french and words in dutch the
reason is that
being a bilingual city everything in
brussels
is by law mandated to be available in
both of these languages
and obviously this goes for street names
and town names etc
these are all given on google maps well
depending on your
language settings but generally given in
both languages
and the same goes for street names on
the actual street as well
and there's actually a whole set of laws
about advertisements
magazines public forums anything which
is textual and you might need in the
city
which needs to be provided in both
languages i've gotten really interesting
booklets where the front is french and
the back is dutch or vice versa
and when you're in any institution
like the local parliament or your city
hall or anything like that
you should generally be able to be
spoken to
in your own native language whichever
that may be and i may have painted the
picture that brussels is a completely
french-speaking city but it's definitely
not
and there are still dutch or flemish
speaking whatever you want to say people
in the city as well
and people who even distinguish
themselves very strictly from the
flemish people outside of brussels in
the actual region of landers
which makes it all the more interesting
but there's of course
another reason why brussels is a really
interesting city as well
[Music]
so as most of us europeans will probably
know and hopefully also people from
other parts of the world but i'm gonna
clarify this
just in case brussels is the de facto
capital of the european union because
it's not
officially the seat of the european
union and
it also kinda shares that title with
strasbourg and france which people are
always annoyed by because every now and
then the parliament has to go to
strasbourg to talk it's a whole mess but
really realistically in reality brussels
is where the european
union is located it's where the european
council is the european commission it's
where the european parliament meets it's
where all of the
lobbying organizations are located as
well and
it's where for most of the weekday you
can find
most of the european politicians as long
as it's not a lockdown situation
and they don't have actual physical
meetings
so yeah it's basically the capital of
europe
which is interesting because it never
really specifically chose
to be the capital of europe it just kind
of became that over time
for a whole bunch of complicated reasons
as well but mostly it's because it just
kind of worked out that way
now i don't know if this has been a
completely positive thing for brussels
as a city
because for better or worse people like
to refer to brussels
as being the european union in a sense
so that when whenever the european union
comes up with
new legislature for its member states
people like to say that brussels has
decided something
or some news came out of brussels which
is all
fair and i definitely don't want to go
into my opinion on the european union
that's a can of worms that
shouldn't be opened in a regular city
skylines video i think
um but i do feel like people are
misrepresenting the city when they are
referring to brussels as being the
european union
when in reality most people that live in
brussels have
nothing to do with it and the
institutions of the eu
are about as far removed from them as
they are from anybody else living in any
other european city
in a very literal sense i mean
the european district in the city is
kind of its own place
with lots of offices and homes of
eurocrats
but not quite as much interchange
between that neighborhood and the other
neighborhoods of the city
it's almost kind of a bubble and i think
it's experienced that way by both people
who work for the european union
and people elsewhere in the city of
course there's a lot of interchange from
it and many jobs are generated by it
but the eu does not really represent the
city or vice versa
not to mention that as a political
center brussels is a lot more than the
eu
alone there are also nato headquarters
and a number of other international
organizations
that make it a political center in
general
which i think kind of gets overshadowed
by its role as an eu capital but it's
definitely something that's a huge part
of the city's identity as well
it's just a very international
globalized political center
anyway let's go back to the game and the
city at hand
because there are a couple of
neighborhoods that i've been working on
that i haven't said much about
yet brussels is basically split
into a slightly larger eastern half and
a slightly smaller western half by a
canal going straight through the middle
of the city
originally there used to be a river
going through the city called the zenith
which is very similar to the name of the
river going through paris but
spelt slightly different even if it's in
french or dutch
but anyway we now have a canal splitting
the city and
on the western half we find the
municipalities of molembake
anderlecht and cucumber among others
and what's interesting about this i
guess
is uh these are historically some of the
poorer
and more working-class neighborhoods and
to this day you find that they have a
very mixed zoning with lots of industry
dispersed throughout the residential
neighborhoods and
supposedly this has something to do
actually with their elevation
these are also the lowest lying parts of
the city
and so while all of the rich aristocrats
historically would be in uk and
in out of him living on the hills in the
forest
in a very nice green environment all of
the factories would be down
in the the lowest parts of the valley
here and thus
this is also where we find many of the
working-class
neighborhoods historically what's also
interesting about cities in general is
that
working class neighborhoods are usually
found underneath the smoke
from industrial zones so very often
depending on whatever the dominant
direction of the
the wind is in a certain area you'll
find
the uh the working class neighborhoods
just to that direction from the
industrial areas
but in brussels we just find them around
the industry
uh in in the middle of these hills which
the city is otherwise
lying on anyway it's time to go through
to some slightly more chic areas of the
western parts of the city
[Music]
by the way my apologies if i completely
butcher some of these names even after
living in brussels i can't get rid of my
dutchness and um my french still sucks
and then there's the problem of having
to choose which language i pronounce
some of the names of these
municipalities in and some of them are
the same in french and dutch
and others are just pronounced
differently and others again
are spelt completely differently so for
instance
the french excel becomes elsina in dutch
and then watermal is just
watermelon in both languages anyway here
we find
uh jet yet and
lachen which lachen is a neighborhood
around where the the royal estate is
located there's a huge park here
most of which is completely unaccessible
to the public for most of the year
unless it's spring and people can visit
the gardens and the greenhouses
on the royal park and they're absolutely
beautiful
really cool uh would recommend if you're
ever around brussels to check
if the time that you're going there
actually lines up
with the time that the greenhouses are
open because it's one of the most cool
things you can visit there
but yeah that's what this neighborhood
is also according to the statistics
it's one of the parts where dutch is
relatively
more prominently spoken than other
languages with the neighborhood
with most french speakers being around
excel where you also find lots of
people who are actually from france who
are quite a
significant part of the population of
brussels anyway moving on to some of the
last neighborhoods
[Music]
and so we get to some of the
northernmost municipalities within the
city with skyerbake which is relatively
well known for train world which is its
train museum and
if you're into trains and given that
you're watching a city skylines video
you very well might be i would highly
recommend visiting it if you're ever
around brussels
and also just to the north of that we
have avere which
is one of the last municipalities to be
added to the city of brussels
in 1954 so a very recent addition
and even to this day i guess one of the
last
you know parts of the the brussels
capital region that you'll see
before you enter the region of flanders
although then again
once you cross the border it doesn't
really change into a different city
and borders are just kind of
you know a little bit arbitrary
i guess and i think this goes especially
for brussels where
the city functionally kind of extends
outside of its regional borders
it just happens to be that you go into a
different region as far as politics are
concerned
and with that i would like to conclude
this video but not before doing
a few plugs first of all i've talked
about my master's thesis of course
in this video and i'm also just going to
link it down in the description so you
can have a look at it yourself
i would say it's uh it's not perfect and
there are definitely things that could
be improved about it i'll
very honestly admit that sometimes it
was a little bit rushed and especially
during the lockdown situation
it was difficult to make it quite as
good as i wanted it to be
but given that i'm talking about it in
this video and that it has
a pretty decent overview i guess of real
world case studies of city skylines
as well as interviews with players
and asset creators and paradox
interactive people
i think it's probably an interesting
read if you're interested in the topic
of city skylines and serious gaming
specifically
and it's probably something that i'm
going to refer a bit more to
in future videos as well and honestly
i do want to do more in the topic beyond
just
this time lapse of making brussels so
it's a bit of a taste of what's to come
and of course if you have any thoughts
about city skylines or
urban planning or public participation
please do share it in the comment
section
or tweet at me on twitter or post it in
my discord i'll
post a link to that in the description
as well wherever it is whatever you want
to say
i am interested in hearing all you guys
thoughts about this topic
and um yeah hope you guys enjoyed this
video
and i hope to see you again in the next
one
[Music]